bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono famiglie ben
tornati anche su out perché è il secondo
episodio di out da un pezzo che non
metto video su questo videogame però ho
saputo che lingua è arabo tedesco ho
visto le scritte ragazzi tipo in
giamaica non so che lingua è ma almeno
sono in inglese vabbè comunque avevo già
fatto un episodio su svende round il
primo mi avete detto che hanno fatto un
update infatti lo vedo completamente
diverso da quello di prima
e avete detto che è cambiato quasi
completamente ci sono un casino di
novità io lo voglio fare perché mi avete
detto che diverso e niente abbiamo
promesso un secondo episodio di questo
anche di slam berger fondo vero tempo di
fare anche quello lo metterò magari
mentre state vedendo questo video lavoro
già messo sindaco non lo so vabbè
comunque vado avanti
cerco di non fare il video di zanda
tutti attaccati che dopo un po annoiano
vabbè comunque oddio ma la crociera così
anche nell'altro no no non era così non
si vedono neanche la mano
ok ragazzi subito novità non era così
l'ultima volta mi ricordo che la torcia
era luminosissima che dà un fastidio
incredibile e mi avevate mi avete anche
consigliato che si può diminuire la
luminosità con la rotellina e non lo
sapevo vabbè comunque
questo nome ringrazia e la foto va bene
che succede lo zio cos'è mai
oddio che cazzo è successo poi aprite
aprite aprite
ma che cazzo era ma di già lo slam ma
quella da rose lander ragazzi si muove
ma da quando 30 si muove
no no no cutie gli utili chiudi la porta
zio ma quello era lo slider
ma da quando mentre guardi lo spendere
inizia a muoversi è una novità questa
non lo sapevo e inquietante non è bello
che ha posto subito immediatamente sono
anche non sono anche partito ok ragazzi
si prospetta una partita abbastanza
complicata allora noi siamo qui avevo
capito
vado a sinistra andiamo di nuovo in casa
se mi ricordo bene quasi mi piacerà a
casa
no vabbè ma così non mi piace
che vengo alla luce perché secondo me
vedo meglio però poi non vedete voi non
so se mi vedete prego di sì perché vedo
che i new year mi c'è qualcuno 10
qualcuno in casa merda ma dove
entro dentro subito chiudi mi dirà poi
chiudi la porta emiliana
ma dove c'è un telefono cos'è save game
ma si può salvare ragazzi ma dove lo
studente mi sta facendo cura un ora a ok
ho trovato riparo dentro ragazzi cè un
interferenza continua ma non vedo lo
slider
non mi piace sarà fuori intorno che gira
per casa
ho notato che si può salvare con un
problema solo dato la partita va bene
mentre mi precipitavo in fretta e furia
va dentro hanno fatto che c'è qualcuno
all'interno della casa
oggi e se per tutta la porto dentro sale
non è che lo slider quello che sono da
cercare qua dentro
sì malaga non vedo niente
oddio oddio chiudi cv dichiari che sia
partiti immediatamente più via di qua ce
lo svenderà in casa dc nero santissimo
devo riuscire a raggiungere il mio amico
che stanno partire una pagina trovate
me ne vado me ne vado immediatamente
ragazzi perché devo dovrei riuscire ad
aggiungere mio amico che è salita però
non so come raggiungerlo probabilmente
da fuori via via di pavia non puoi non
posso aiutarti scusami cielo slant al di
sopra
a parte che non ci sei più riguardo
lo studente che mi stava crollando
inizio a pensare quello va bene comunque
non sei molto ospitale che me ne vado
perché via di qua immediatamente via
subito ragazzino non ci ho capito niente
di quello che è successo non ho capito
se quello che cercava aiuterà lo slang
che tentava di fottermi anzi siamo di
nuovo qui ok andiamo a destra che c'e la
torre quella enorme con sopra il divano
insensato sì però ragazzi se posso darti
rincorre
oddio dov'è
no no no no no stai lontano
immediatamente dov'è dov'è andato non
vedo più ragazzi oddio è una cosa
impressionante questo perché ti mette la
tensione assurda il fatto che che ti
segue
in teoria non dovrebbe esservi al tifoso
lenta non è mai stato così perché dovete
rompermi le palle a me sono riuscito a
trovare la torre non so come non
chiedetemelo ma va bene così
ap no l'occhio ad un cazzo aprì subito
perché è chiusa ma scavalca la ringhiera
un bambino riuscirebbe a farlo la
foresta il posto peggiore me ne vado ma
se è così ragazzi è molto più difficile
di quello di prima ma parecchio
indicazioni do not cross
oddio non vedo niente tappa che cazzo è
successo poi sono slancio che sono
pianta avvelenata non attraversare non
ci tengo grazie mille
faccio il giro da sempre pianta benenati
si ok
spero che lo salendoci passi in mezzo
glielo auguro con tutto il cuore per
tutto il bene che ti voglio
ok ho un mio è che palle però ma fatti
un mazzo di cazzi tua però devi sempre
un po le balle a me comunque devo andare
di qua dove l'agire aggirare il campo di
grano questo non è un campo di
avvelenato in campo di grano ok allora
qua ci fosse passare tranquillamente
senza che il pezzente mi venga addosso
se speriamo
vabbè io mi fido di me stesso cosa
pessima però vabbè vedo qualcosa che
lampeggia vedo vedo qualcosa
aspettate dov'è il televisore mio eccolo
perfetto c'è anche fini frankestein
starei a guardarlo però guarda non è
proprio la situazione adatta per poterlo
fare quindi vado nella casa abbandonata
che mi sembra un posto tranquillissimo
per poter andare in video game on
la casa abbandonata si trova oltre
dopodiché ok vedo poi un'altra pagina
quest'anno la ricordavo ragazzi
ho sentito il verso di un orco non me lo
ricordavo adesso non lo so ho ricordato
c'era anche nel primo io esco di qua me
ne vado via
[Musica]
ok se non sbaglio ora devo andare tutto
dritto e
mi sa che sbatte ma c'era questa prima
non c'era l'anno aggiunto degli alberi
perfetto non mi do giocato non mi fosse
un mesetto fa l'altro surrender cioè il
primo episodio di questo salento non lo
ricordo bene
comunque non posso oltrepassare questo
punto e vabbè
intanto lo ha già visto qualcosa
laggiù è quella la casa abbandonata e
stavo sbagliando direzione
non la vedete non avete un anch'io
tranquilli ma tra un po spunta devo
smettere di correre
ok vado prima a sinistra ragazzi che sto
vedendo preso un pò eficio cioè una
capanna africa edificio
[Musica]
come non detto torniamo dove eravamo
prima c'è la casa abbandonata che lì
davanti anche se non la vedete adesso
appare siamo tranquilli
vedo anche tipo una fabbrica in fondo
anche se si vede a stento vuoi vedere se
andarci anche se non mi ispira
moltissimo comunque va bene
sarebbe interessante vederlo di giorno
sto parco perché se come di giorno anche
carino che succede vai piano
no perché è bello che appaiono
interferenze me non c'è un cazzo di
nessuno ma qua c'è questo passo
ufficiale nel primo ritorno
nella versione precedente mi sa che non
c'erano solo i ragazzi non me lo ricordo
proprio
payne red vabbè darci tua guarda faq
partner a banche a barre nei rami che
anch'io in a place like that he lo
guarda più che altro mi spaventerei
dello slider non del bunker
dice una porta che comunque non ci si
arriva ci sarà un autoporto io entrerei
prima che che succeda qualcosa di brutto
ok perfetto
siamo dentro spegne la luce non si sa
mai tanto vedete no spero di sì
l'ha fatto
ma nel bunker mi sento più assicuro cosa
questo batteria
perfetto il bunka da cosa è quello
un'altra macchina da scrivere salviamo
ragazzi you found the greater ho
finalmente la pagina e scrubs
va bene non sembra esserci nient'altro
parte un'altra cosa ma c'è ancora
cos'è oddio ammazza un mega scivolo
questo
un interferenza con vista non me la sono
segnata stavolta devo pregare che non ci
sia in fondo perché inizio a darmela
gambe come un bambino
processo che cazzo serve sto posto ma
spiegatemelo c'è un acceso sono stato
due a scendere che ti serve va bene
torniamo indietro c'è da allora uno
scivolo enorme che poi non è uno scivolo
facciamo vedere se non si va e poi alla
fine non c'è niente che cosa lo mettono
a fare ma scusatemi ma speriamo di non
beccarsi losone da vinci ma perché sono
sono [ __ ] la stragrande perfetto che
le sto tirando oddio questa
lo sa
e spuntato dal muro non è eccessivo che
spunti dal muro no vabbè ragazzi a tutto
c'è un limite non potete fanno in
messico
fortunatamente oggi sono già confuso di
mio quindi ancora non non è che mi sono
preso tutti sti colpi però questo alla
fine è stato abbastanza potente ho paura
fare altri episodi magari quando mi
sento un po meglio li faccio niente deve
essere piaciuto video lasciato mi piace
lasciate un commento qui sotto anche mi
piace la pagina di facebook è trovata in
descrizione
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi ci
vediamo prossimo video bei ragazzi